the first clinical trial is underway
testing a new male contraceptive that
could be a game-changer for preventing
pregnancy the National Institutes of
Health are enrolling about 420 couples
to use an experimental gel if proven
effective it would be the first hormonal
birth control for men the gel is applied
daily to the back and shoulders it's
absorbed through the skin and blocks the
production of sperm our dr. Tara Narula
is here to talk about this Tara good
morning morning glad
so why apply a gel instead of just
taking a pill it sounds very interesting
so testosterone given orally is cleared
from the body very quickly so they found
that the gel getting it through the skin
is absorbed and stays in the system
longer so this products been in
development for over 10 years and
basically what it is is a combination of
two hormones progestin which is the
typical hormone that is found actually
in female oral contraceptive pills which
they put in there to suppress sperm
production to trick the body and
testosterone which is the male sex
hormone so that there's normal
circulating levels of testosterone so
that men don't lose their libido or
their sexual function or have any
changes in mood so in this study the men
are going to apply the gel to their
upper arms skin of their shoulders every
single day and then the researchers are
going to monitor their sperm count over
a couple months when the sperm count has
declined enough they're gonna tell the
couples only use the gel as your form of
oral contraception and they're gonna
watch them for one year and then they're
gonna see the effectiveness of
preventing pregnancy and they're gonna
ask the couples how did you like using
the gel then they're gonna go on and
follow them in for about six months
after to see if their sperm counts
recover so does it like a birth control
pill in other words you have to use the
gel every single day you have to use it
every day exactly and what about when
couples decide that they do want to
conceive right so the nice thing about
this and most of the drugs that they're
studying that are hormonal like this the
sperm counts do seem to go up when the
gel stops and so the suppression that
they want to achieve is less than 1
million sperm per milliliter and then
normal sperm counts are greater than 15
million per milliliter so you do want to
see that and it usually happens over a
couple months so it's not permanent it
is not perfect most of the
responsibility for birth control has
been on women and it's been 50 years
right since the FDA approved the pill is
this part of a change in terms of
looking at new ways to provide
contraception for both sexes I think
absolutely and so real
have had condoms vasectomy and
withdrawal none of these are really
ideal and there have been a couple
issues as to why we don't see this in
them for men yet and one has to do with
the biology of it it's much more
difficult to suppress the development of
a hundred and fifty million sperm per
day than it is to suppress one or two
eggs per month it's also a normal state
for women to be pregnant where you can
give them an oral contraceptive and it
mimics pregnancy it's not really normal
to produce the state in men where
they're not producing sperm the second
has to do with the fact that industry
really has not dipped their toe into
this arena and so it's really been left
to nonprofits and governments to do
research on this and also the regulatory
issue is there the regulatory standards
a lot higher in this case for men it's
also nice to see that the onus isn't
always on the woman right this is an
option powder program gender equity app
for that for that is the one male at the
page they're enrolling
[Laughter]
[Music]